175 тисяч російських військових поблизу українського кордону,
які - попри всі застереження Заходу - нікуди не діваються.
Як можна стримати Росію? На всіх західних майданчиках лунає одне:
Нам треба дати сильну відповідь.
Ми разом забезпечимо для Москви серйозні наслідки її дій.
Ідеться про нові санкції. Але які саме? Чим вони відрізнятимуться від тих, що були раніше?
Коли їх запровадять? І чи здатні вони змінити наміри Путіна?
Ідеться про скоординовані санкції США, ЄС і Великобританії. Конкретних рішень
і чітких обіцянок поки немає. Адже й приводу поки немає.
Санкції запроваджуватимуть лише у разі відкритого військового наступу Росії.
У таких ситуаціях треба чекати на краще і готуватися до гіршого.
Так ми приблизно й робимо. У підготовці до гіршого ми зараз думаємо
про стримування, намагаємося запобігти кризі, запобігти військовим діям.
Ми переконані, що Росія дійсно готується до повномасштабної війни проти України.
Це безпрецедентна подія. Це означає, що потрібна безпрецедентна відповідь від західних держав.
Заяви Вашингтона більш загрозливі й конкретні. У разі військових кроків РФ,
йтиметься про економічні санкції.
Якщо Росія піде шляхом конфронтації і військових дій, ми чітко дали Москві зрозуміти,
що відповімо рішуче. Зокрема й за допомогою таких економічних заходів,
які вважаємо ефективними, й до яких раніше ще не вдавалися.
Які економічні заходи мав на увазі у Держдепі? За інформацією CNN
із посиланням на власні джерела, якщо Кремль піде шляхом ескалації,
США і Європа можуть застосувати санкції проти найближчого оточення
президента РФ Володимира Путіна, енергетичних компаній, банків, російського держборгу
і російських олігархів. За даними CNN, американці начебто розглядають
і так звану "ядерну опцію" - відключення Москви від платіжної системи SWIFT.
Про такі наміри Вашингтона стало відомо напередодні відеопереговорів
Байдена з Путіним минулого тижня.
Я дивлюся вам в очі зараз і говорю те саме, що говорив президент Байден,
дивлячись в очі Володимиру Путіну: те, що ми не зробили в 2014-му, ми готові зробити зараз.
На що ж нині готові піти Сполучені Штати і Європа, аби захистити Україну?
Найрадикальнішим, тим самим "ядерним" заходом називають можливе відключення Росії
від міжнародної платіжної системи SWIFT. Про таку можливість у Вашингтоні
не говорять офіційно, але ЗМІ постійно про це згадують.
SWIFT - це об'єднання банків з усіх країн світу. У системі проходить більшість
безготівкових розрахунків, зокрема й за експорт та імпорт товарів і послуг між державами.
Це така кровоносна система в економіці. У вас можуть бути чудові органи, красиві очі,
сильні руки, але якщо кровоносна система не переносить кисень, то через кілька хвилин
ви почнете помирати. Так само і з сучасною економікою: якщо не проходять платежі, економіка помирає.
Відключення від SWIFT - потужніший удар, ніж усі раніше запроваджені санкції.
Але чи застосує Захід таку "ядерну опцію" - експерти сумніваються.
Насамперед, бо в такому разі Європа не зможе розраховуватися з Росією
за енергоресурси й ризикує замерзнути.
Відключення Росії від платіжної системи SWIFT стане серйозним ударом,
адже це може безпосередньо торкнутися російського експорту енергоресурсів,
а саме їхньої оплати. Чи вирішать зрештою дістати таку зброю - не можу сказати.
Але є й низка технічних перешкод. Фінансові інститути виступатимуть проти такого кроку,
бо він ускладнить їхню роботу.
Але заперечення можна подолати лише, якщо буде політична воля.
З іншого боку, чимало фахівців не вважають навіть "ядерну опцію" тотально руйнівною.
Адже вона наче дамоклів меч висить над Кремлем з 2014 року.
Тож у Москві вже встигли підготуватися і створити власну платіжну систему-аналог,
яка вже забезпечує п'яту частину принаймні внутрішніх фінансових операцій.
Навіть якщо це станеться, Росія вже деякий час готується до жорстких санкцій,
включаючи відключення Росії від системи SWIFT. Я не думаю,
що це буде згубно для неї, оскільки раніше Росії вдалося пережити доволі серйозні санкції.
Я думаю, що Кремль сподівається, що життя можливе і під ще жорсткішими санкціями.
І для цього є певні підстави.
Ще один потужний, але суперечливий варіант -  енергетичний удар.
Тобто обмеження, а то й заборона на купівлю російських нафти й газу.
На думку експертів, Вашингтон може собі дозволити обійтися без енергоносіїв з РФ,
тоді як Європа на таке піде лише в крайньому разі.
Чи можливий консенсус між США і Європою в надзвичайній ситуації? Я не певен у цьому.
Тому що у відповідь на таке Росія може перервати постачання газу чи скоротити його.
І все це взимку, коли дефіцит газу й так становить вже близько 50 мільярдів кубометрів.
Водночас я впевнений, що якщо станеться те, що в Німеччині називають
серйозною агресією з боку Росії в Україні, то такі санкції запровадять.
І Штати, і Європа мають у своєму арсеналі ще один потужний важіль впливу на Кремль
- це "Північний потік-2". Нова міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
Анналена Бербок однозначно заявила: якщо буде ескалація в Україні,
російською трубою газ не піде. У Вашингтоні з такою позицією солідарні.
Я не знаю потужнішого засобу покарати Росію за агресію, ніж поставити хрест
на досягнутому прогресі і, якщо це можливо, запобігти запуску "Північного потоку-2".
Це обговорюється із союзниками?
Звичайно. Якщо згадаєте спільну заяву США й Німеччини в липні,
то там саме про це і йшлося.
Російська агресія проти України безпосередньо відіб'ється на газогоні.
Слухайте, безпосередньо відіб'ється це одне. Але я буквально говорю
про згортання проєкту, називайте це як хочете.
Я маю на увазі - зробити так, аби він ніколи не запрацював.
Думаю, якщо Володимир Путін почне наступ на Україну, ми очікуватимемо,
що введення "Потоку" в експлуатацію призупинять.
На думку експертів, найбільш реалістичний варіант для США і ЄС
- прямі санкції проти російських банків і компаній, які відріжуть їх від можливості
проводити розрахунки валютою із західними банками. Або ж - розширення "чорного списку"
російських олігархів. У будь-якому разі зрозуміло одне: якщо нові санкції й будуть,
то вони стосуватимуться економіки.
Важливим елементом зі США є те, що у Вашингтоні обіцяють відповісти
економічними заходами, а не військовими. Таким чином Росія знає,
що військової відповіді не буде. Так, будуть економічні наслідки,
але воювати за Україну США наміру не мають.
Але ж економічні санкції вже запроваджені - з 2014 року. У "чорних списках" США
- понад півтисячі російських компаній і більш як три сотні осіб.
Під санкціями ЄС - дещо менше. Оцінити ефект таких заходів складно.
У 2019 році МВФ підрахував, що за попередні чотири роки санкції коштували
російській економіці лише 0,2 відсотка щорічного росту ВВП.
Утім, деякі експерти стверджують, що вплив був масштабнішим.
Тим не менше, Росія навчилася жити з цим - створила власну платіжну систему,
зменшила залежність від долара, наростила ресурси "на чорний день".
Більше того - санкції не змусили володаря Кремля відступити з українських кордонів.
До того ж, нагадаємо, Захід планує нові санкції лише у разі нової військової агресії.
А такий сценарій аж ніяк не влаштовує Україну. Утім, на думку фахівців,
сама лише загроза санкцій все ж може подіяти як запобіжник.
Поки Росія не пішла великою війною проти України - це малоймовірно.
Ніхто цього робити не буде. Ця загроза лежить на столі, щоб Росія розуміла,
що може статися, якщо вони це зроблять.
Коли санкції введені, вони вже перестають стримувати.
Стримують ті санкції, які лежать перед вами, і ви знаєте, що за це буде.
Водночас CNN наводить іншу думку радника українського президента,
який забажав залишитися невідомим. Посадовець закликав до санкцій "тут і зараз".
І заявив: у Києві вважають, що антиросійські санкції постфактум,
тобто після можливого військового наступу, будуть марними.
Адже тоді намагатися вплинути на хід думок людей у Кремлі буде запізно.